este vídeo ha sido posible gracias al
surf shark vpn luego os doy más detalles
pero antes vamos con nuestra historia de
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la pandemia del nuevo shark coronavirus
2 no sólo es una crisis de salud pública
también es una crisis económica y detrás
de los números de las gráficas y de las
estadísticas están las auténticas
tragedias tragedias muy reales como este
[Música]
nissan cierra su planta de barcelona con
3000 trabajadores afectados y no sólo
hablamos de 3.000 personas que acaban de
perder su trabajo una fábrica de coches
genera miles de empleos indirectos
alrededor de la fábrica de nissan había
un montón de empresas auxiliares
empresas que fabricaban componentes para
el motor tubos de frenos tubos de escape
y un montón de cosas más en total
hablamos de más de 25 mil personas en
barcelona que casi seguro que perderán
su trabajo hablamos de todo un drama y
puede que no sea la última fábrica de
coches que cierre en españa- pero seguro
que nada de esto os va a sorprender
nadie discute que el coronavirus nos ha
traído una recesión global durante todo
este año 2020 casi todos los países van
a entrar en crisis económica y en
recesión
la pregunta es hablamos de una crisis
más o del apocalipsis zombie
y como siempre la respuesta no es ni sí
ni no sino depende por ejemplo en
república checa el paro a duras penas ha
subido al cinco por ciento por supuesto
que también están en crisis pero es una
crisis mucho más suave sin embargo hay
otros sectores económicos y sobre todo
otros países donde si podemos hablar de
un auténtico apocalipsis zombie la
versión económica de the walking dead y
si uno de estos países es españa
bruselas prevé que el pib caiga un 94
por ciento y el paro suba al 18 9% en
españa en 2020 exacto todo apunta a que
tanto españa como italia van a ser los
mayores perjudicados por esta crisis por
un lado son dos de los países más
afectados por lo que viene siendo la
crisis sanitaria en el momento en el que
hacemos este vídeo españa es el segundo
país del mundo en tasa de mortalidad
sólo superado por bélgica en bélgica es
que no sé ya que han podido hacer mal
todo esto se debe a una serie de
catastróficas desdichas que os
explicamos en este otro vídeo
pero no sólo eso tanto españa como
italia seguían arrastrando los efectos
de la crisis de 2008 crisis de la que ni
de lejos se habían recuperado para que
os hagáis una idea en el año 2019 españa
tenía un paro de casi el 15 por ciento
en algunas zonas incluso superaba el 20%
hay toda una generación de españoles a
los que llamamos los ninis porque ni
estudian ni trabajan hablamos de gente
que tiene 30 años y que todavía vive con
sus padres porque no ha encontrado un
trabajo estable seguro que muchos de los
que veáis este vídeo desde españa estáis
en esta situación o conocéis a alguien
que lo está es un auténtico drama
nacional y este era el panorama antes de
la pandemia cuando toda europa estaba
creciendo así que imaginad lo que puede
pasar después de la pandemia
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
pero porque hay una crisis es decir vale
bien durante meses se ha parado la
economía todo se ha frenado en seco
todos nos hemos quedado en casa durante
meses casi todas las empresas han dejado
de producir pero cuando todos volvamos
otra vez al trabajo todo debería volver
a la normalidad
[Música]
pues y esto es lo que va a pasar en
muchos casos sin ir más lejos las
acciones de google ya se han recuperado
en bolsa ojo esto no significa que
google o más bien alphabet no tenga
problemas pero esto nos da un poco la
medida de cómo hay sectores que sí se
pueden recuperar
ahora bien imaginado un bar de barrio la
casa manolo que sirve en cocina
tradicional pulpo a la gallega y cañas
de cerveza a dos euros cada una casa
manolo tiene dos trabajadores
el señor manolo y la cocinera que se
llama carmen esteban genera vamos a
decir unos beneficios de unos cuatro mil
euros al mes lo gusto para que el señor
manolo pueda llegar a fin de mes y le
pueda pagar el sueldo a la señora carmen
dos meses sin ingresos pueden suponer el
cierre y eso significa que manolo venda
el bar y carmen se vaya a la calle pues
bien hay miles de casos como éste en
españa y en todas partes pero no sólo
hablamos de barrios también hay grandes
empresas que no estaban preparadas para
una cuarentena empresas como ésta
[Aplausos]
[Música]
dice que el coronavirus ha diezmado sus
beneficios llevándole a la bancarrota
sin embargo todo esto es una tendencia
global ahora la pregunta es por qué
españa está teniendo más problemas que
el resto de países qué peculiaridades
tiene la economía española que no tenga
a la alemana o la estadounidense y lo
que es más importante hay alguna forma
de evitar el apocalipsis zombie hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes tenemos que hablar de internet si
hay alguien que no ha perdido el trabajo
son los hackers pensando bien durante
estos días de cuarentena y coronavirus
hemos visto algo así como la versión
online de chicago años 30 no lo digo yo
lo dicen todos los estudios de
ciberseguridad
[Música]
estafas filtraciones de datos y robo de
privacidad nunca había sido más
peligroso navegar por internet pero
tranquilos existe una vacuna contra los
hackers ya sabes conectarse a internet a
través de una vpn como subsal
[Música]
usar es una vpn fantástica por muchas
razones seguro que todos sabéis que ha
ido alguna vez en una de estas webs de
spam que intentan estafar os con popups
a este tipo de prácticas se les llama
phishing pues bien su usar tiene una
herramienta que se llama clean web que
bloquea todos estos popup si todos estos
enlaces que pueden ser un auténtico
peligro
[Música]
pero no sólo eso con una única cuenta de
sub shark podéis registrar todos los
dispositivos que queráis el móvil la
tablet el portátil no hay ningún límite
de dispositivos y como siempre tenemos
una oferta muy especial para todos
vosotros que seguís visual políti
básicamente si utilizáis el código
político terminado inca tendréis un 85%
de descuento más tres meses extra
totalmente gratis es más podéis probar
su usar durante los primeros 30 días sin
ningún compromiso en la descripción
os dejo todos los detalles y dicho esto
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la tormenta perfecta en toda crisis hay
ganadores y perdedores empresas como
amazon o netflix han salido ganando con
el coronavirus y os preguntaréis y
quiénes son las mayores víctimas de la
pandemia pues creo que ya os lo podéis
imaginar las aerolíneas se trata del
último sector en abrir tras la
cuarentena y muchas no han sobrevivido
ni sobrevivirán
avianca una de las mayores aerolíneas de
latinoamérica se declara en bancarrota y
qué sectores están mejor preparados para
sobrevivir a la crisis pues aparte de
las empresas de internet podemos hablar
de la industria muchas fábricas han
podido adaptarse a la cuarentena por
ejemplo para hacer este vídeo estuvimos
hablando con un directivo de atlas copco
en república checa atlas copco es una
multinacional que fabrica compresores de
aire máquinas de vacío y en general lo
que viene siendo maquinaria industrial
todos los veranos aprovechan las
vacaciones para hacer tareas de
mantenimiento es decir limpiar las
máquinas revisarlas arreglar las
engrasar las pues lo típico tareas de
mantenimiento pues bien este año en
lugar de hacerlo en verano lo han hecho
durante la cuarentena lo mismo está
pasando con otras muchas empresas sin
embargo dentro de la industria hay un
sector que sí lo está pasando
especialmente mal y no hablamos de un
sector cualquiera hablamos de este
sector
el golpe del coronavirus a la industria
de los automóviles puede ser incluso más
grande que los últimos pronósticos si
seguís visual político desde hace tiempo
ya lo sabéis porque lo hemos contado
varias veces los grandes fabricantes de
coches llevaban años en crisis para que
os hagáis una idea antes de la pandemia
fitch que es una agencia de calificación
de deuda consideraba que la deuda de
renault era un 'bono basura' pues bien
si el grupo renault ya estaba en una
mala situación la pandemia les ha puesto
al borde de la bancarrota
para que os hagáis una idea en 2018 las
acciones de renault cotizaban a unos
noventa y ocho euros en febrero del 2020
es decir antes de la crisis estaban ya
por los treinta euros pues bien un mes
más tarde han llegado a estar en los
quince euros todo un descalabro que ha
obligado a la empresa a sentarse y tomar
decisiones drásticas por el momento ya
han dicho que van a despedir a quince
mil personas en todo el mundo y los
primeros tres mil estaban en barcelona
[Música]
nissan cierra su fábrica en barcelona y
sus 3000 empleados se quedan sin trabajo
durante la crisis de el coronavirus y lo
cierto es que no son los únicos ni
santín otras dos plantas en españa una
en ávila y otra en santander pero es que
renault tiene otras tres plantas
valladolid palencia y sevilla puede que
os sorprenda
e incluso a muchos de los españoles que
estáis viendo este vídeo pero españa es
el segundo productor de coches de europa
sólo por detrás de alemánia españa es
uno de los grandes líderes del motor es
más uno de los principales fabricantes
de componentes de coches es una empresa
española que se llama el grupo antolín y
ese es justo uno de los sectores que
peor lo está pasando ahora mismo
[Música]
así que ahora vamos a hacer una pequeña
recapitulación dos de los sectores más
afectados por el coronavirus son el
turismo y la automoción pues bien el
turismo supone el 11 por ciento del pib
de españa y la automoción el 87 por
ciento en total hablamos de casi el 20
por ciento del pib de españa es decir
que la quinta parte de la economía está
seriamente afectada por el coronavirus y
diréis vale y qué pasa con el otro 80%
pues lo cierto es que tampoco tiene
buenas perspectivas volvamos al ejemplo
de casa manolo el típico bar de barrio
que tiene uno o dos trabajadores es
decir eso es lo que llamaríamos una
microempresa el tipo de negocio más
expuesto a la pandemia pues bien atentos
a este gráfico
si os dais cuenta en alemania el 82% de
las pymes son lo que llamamos
microempresas en españa y en italia
hablamos del 95% y todo esto qué
significa os lo hemos contado ya en
vídeos anteriores alemania es una
economía muy sólida gracias en parte a
tener muchas medianas empresas por
ejemplo desma es una empresa alemana que
tiene poco más de 200 trabajadores son
los líderes mundiales en fabricar
máquinas que a su vez fabrican suelas de
zapatos y lo sé se trata de un nicho muy
específico pero creedme en eso de sma
son el número uno vender en todas partes
china eeuu españa allí donde se fabrican
suelas de zapatos es muy probable que
hay una máquina de sesma por cierto que
no están patrocinando este vídeo ni
muchísimo menos pero era un buen ejemplo
que me venía muy bien para el guión pues
bien seguramente en esta empresa también
tengan problemas con la crisis pero
tienen los suficientes ahorros y son lo
suficientemente competitivos como para
poder aguantar un mal año sin tener que
echarle el cierre sin embargo una
microempresa como casa
lo que tampoco patrocina este vídeo lo
tiene mucho más complicado para que os
hagáis una idea una empresa mediana
alemania tiene 76 empleados en españa es
el 39
en otras palabras en españa tenemos
grandes empresas por un lado y
microempresas por el otro a duras penas
hay un término medio esto se traduce en
que españa está mucho más expuesta a
cualquier crisis económica
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
por fin ha llegado el momento en el que
los estados van a tener que rescatar la
economía verdad es decir antes de que
casa manolo vaya a echar el cierre llega
el estado español y le da una subvención
o un préstamo para que pueda cubrir
todos los agujeros que le ha dejado la
pandemia pues si tenéis toda la razón
creo que incluso los más liberales
estarán de acuerdo en que en momentos
así hace falta ayuda del estado
[Música]
a fin de cuentas el estado en cierto
modo no es más que una mega mutua de
seguros y si hay un momento donde las
empresas aseguradas necesitan que le
rescaten es ahora el problema pues de
nuevo el problema es que no todos los
estados son iguales y el estado español
no está precisamente en el mejor momento
si antes hablábamos del apocalipsis
zombie de the walking dead' ahora
tenemos que hablar de
the walking dead' da igual si son de
izquierdas o de derechas todos los
gobiernos del mundo están ayudando a sus
empresas en total los países europeos se
han gastado ya más de dos billones de
euros en rescatar su economía y si digo
billones en español es decir 12 seguido
de 12 ceros en inglés diríamos trillions
pues bien casi la mitad de esos dos
millones de euros corresponden a
alemania por ejemplo recordáis que os
decía que muchas aerolíneas están
echando al cierre pues alemania ya está
haciendo todo lo posible por evitarlo al
menos en su territorio
llega un acuerdo con la unión europea
para rescatar a lufthansa por 9 mil 900
millones de dólares y si alemania ha
tenido que pedir permiso a la unión
europea porque la legislación
comunitaria prohíbe que los gobiernos
rescaten a sus propias empresas se trata
de una violación del principio de la
libre competencia sin embargo hablamos
de una situación extraordinaria y en un
momento así bruselas está permitiendo
cosas que antes serían totalmente
ilegales
pero la pregunta es quién paga todo esto
es decir tanto dinero tiene alemania
como para poder ir por ahí rescatando a
todas sus empresas como si no existiera
mañana pues lo cierto es que no alemania
al igual que españa francia o italia van
a tener que pedir todo ese dinero
prestado
hablamos de bonos de deuda que se emiten
al mercado y diréis vale y dónde está el
problema que me cuentas fonseca porque
alemania puede endeudarse y españa no y
aquí es donde sale a la luz otro de los
grandes problemas de españa la deuda
pública alemana equivale a menos del 60
por ciento de su pib en españa este
número está por encima del 95 por ciento
y atentos porque en italia hablamos del
134 por ciento
ahora imaginad que sois un inversor
bueno en realidad muchos de vosotros
sois inversores así que hacemos esta
pregunta qué bono de deuda compraríais
antes el alemán que sabéis que puede
devolverlo cuando ha dicho que lo va a
devolver o el español pues ya está no
hay más preguntas señoría y todo esto
explica lo siguiente
coronavirus la presidenta de la comisión
europea von der leyen dice que el fondo
de recuperación de 750 mil millones de
euros es el momento europeo ya lo
explicamos en este otro vídeo hace un
mes nadie pone en duda que europa tiene
que ayudar a españa o italia la pregunta
es cómo va a venir esa ayuda el primer
debate fue el de los corona bonos en
resumen los países del norte de la zona
euro querían prestar dinero a los países
del sur a cambio de supervisión política
el sur sin embargo quería dinero gratis
y sin condiciones ahora el debate ha
cambiado y ahora es sobre si la ayuda de
europa tiene que venir en forma de
préstamos o de subvenciones y finalmente
en la comisión europea ha llegado a un
punto medio
[Música]
y 500.000 millones de euros en
subvenciones y el gasto público 250 mil
millones de euros en préstamos con un
interés muy bajo ese dinero saldrá de
bonos de deuda que sacará la unión
europea al mercado internacional es muy
probable que muchos de estos bonos los
termine comprando el banco central
europeo es decir es como los corona
bonos pero de forma temporal y la
pregunta la auténtica pregunta es es
esto suficiente basta con mandar dinero
a españa para que la economía española
se recupere pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
[Música]
más excel y power point el dinero es
importante pero no hace milagros el
mejor ejemplo de esto es el tren de alta
velocidad en las últimas décadas europa
ha gastado más de 11 mil millones de
euros para que españa tenga un
ferrocarril de alta velocidad que da
gusto ver
a día de hoy los españoles tienen la
tercera red de alta velocidad más grande
del mundo sólo por detrás de china y
japón- la pregunta es ha servido para
algo
realmente no ya os lo explicamos en
otros vídeos de visual política desde el
punto de vista puramente económico la
alta velocidad española el llamado ave
es un agujero de proporciones de esta
vez vamos a dejarlo en proporciones
colosales proporciones colosales en las
cuentas nacionales y a duras penas ha
servido para generar crecimiento
económico ni siquiera se puede utilizar
para transportar mercancías sólo sirve
para pasajeros y desde el punto de vista
social pues tampoco se puede decir que
haya sido muy útil
un billete de tren en españa' es entre
un 40 y un 100 por ciento más caro que
un trayecto equivalente en alemania o
república checa y lo mismo ocurre con
los aeropuertos fantasma españa tiene
unos cuantos aeropuertos que a duras
penas tienen vuelos de hecho alguno está
vacío pero que han costado una auténtica
fortuna hablamos de miles de millones de
euros que se han gastado por razones
puramente electorales políticas o
incluso ideológicas
[Música]
quiero una situación como ésta lo que
españa necesita es más excel y menos
power point y la pregunta es hasta qué
punto españa está dispuesta a dejar
todas esas rencillas políticas y
centrarse en la pura gestión económica
pues qué queréis que os diga noticias
como estas son bastante decepcionantes
la destitución de un jefe de la guardia
civil provoca una disputa política sobre
la seguridad jurídica el gobierno de
españa' ha entrado en una disputa en la
que se le acusa de subvertir el estado
de derecho y menoscabar la democracia
después de enfrentarse a una de las
instituciones más formidables del país
para los que veáis este vídeo desde
españa si he escogido esta noticia del
financial times a propósito porque me
parece muy importante que entendamos lo
que ocurre en españa desde la prensa
extranjera es decir olvidándonos de
todos los sesgos que tiene la prensa
nacional pero a todo esto hay que
sumarle el hecho de que españa tiene un
gobierno de coalición una coalición
entre los socialistas de centroizquierda
y podemos que es un partido de extrema
izquierda y si pensabais que los
partidos de izquierdas siempre se
entienden bien entre ellos
estabais muy equivocados cada vez hay
más tensión entre lo que podríamos
llamar el ala moderada del gobierno que
el ala más radical y si dentro del
propio gobierno hay tensiones yo os
podéis imaginar lo que pasa con los
partidos de oposición el ambiente
político en españa está muy
[Música]
y esto es preocupante porque en algún
momento al gobierno no le va a quedar
otro remedio que recortar gastos y tomar
medidas impopulares muchas de estas
medidas van a necesitar sí o sí el apoyo
de la oposición al menos de la oposición
más moderada
sin embargo juzgar por vosotros mismos
esto que vais a ver ahora es una escena
del parlamento creo señor espinoza de
los monteros que a ustedes les gustaría
dar un golpe de estado pero que no se
atreven usted es el hijo de un
terrorista
un marxista comunista
cierre al salir señoría así que ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros creéis que
europa puede forzar a los políticos
españoles a ser más responsables es
posible que las ayudas europeas ayuden a
evitar el apocalipsis zombie para que la
crisis sea más llevadera podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a visual polític y darle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si se ha
mostrado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto